that behind me is a van it's my van and
it took a long time to build
I bought the van back in November it is
now September and it is finally finally
done it could use with some improvements
but let me show you the van the latest
improvement was a lift and bigger tires
now I know I posted photos before and
people were making fun of the tires
because they were too small but these
are the big tires so there's a lot of
questions that need to be answered why
do I have a van what's the point of the
van and more importantly what's inside
the van first let's look inside I'll
give you a tour showing you the outside
of the van in a second as well but check
us out so right in front of us right
here well that's a shower this shower is
I don't know it's fully functioning now
a lot of the vans you'll see online have
a closed room we thought that was a bad
idea
because we rarely use the shower so what
Neal did Neal's the guy who basically
built everything he decided to go with
this to this out this shower curtain bar
rod can actually pull out and then you
have wallah shower now there is even a
toilet in here this is the bathroom the
full bathroom so you can see you got
shampoo and toothbrush a little mirror
there and there is a light specifically
for the bathroom now admittedly I don't
use this that often this is more for
emergencies and the purpose of this van
is more so production in the field for
those that aren't familiar with who I am
and what I do I will give you that
rundown as well so as you can see we
have a workstation here now currently
the PlayStation is there and the
Playstations on oh look there's my
pretty face and the fan is currently
running I should turn this off the fans
up here but because of the light I'll do
this
so I produce videos those are not
familiar with my work I was the founding
member of vice news you may have heard
of Vice and so if ice has been around
for really long time but I started doing
on-the-ground reporting and news with
them I ended up traveling the world
producing mini documentaries and things
like that I ended up working for an ABC
company
that and then I went fully independent
and now I have a series of YouTube
channels which I guess do pretty well
for some reason but here's the thing as
I've expanded my content into political
commentary and reporting online there
has been a drought in field reporting
and that's what I love doing more than
anything most of the people you'll see
talking about Vann life and getting a
van to live in look there's the bed it's
kind of messy they do it because they
want adventure
and they do it because they're tired of
the corporate life and they're like some
couple no not me I'm probably gonna end
up traveling on my own which is probably
not a good thing but I'm gonna be
traveling not because I'm looking for
adventure because I'm trying but because
I'm trying to get back to with the
adventure and produce them on-the-ground
reporting and journalism so I have a
background in video production and yeah
I'm gonna be on the ground traveling
that's the main purpose of the venn so
when it comes to things like a shower
and a toilet it's not so much that I'm
gonna be living in here I need a shower
it's just that if I'm in the middle of
nowhere in a desert or something and I
need to get cleaned up because I'm not
gonna have access to a house or hotel
well is it the showers for here there's
a little happy accident as far as what
sitting Bob Ross that has a happy
accident so this is actually behind that
panel is where the plumbing goes however
Neil the guy who essentially designed
and built it all for me is a smart
person and so he put these hooks in here
left and right we can see them up here
and that's where my skateboard goes so
it's actually pretty convenient because
I skate all the time don't mind the
plane
sleeping arrangements this is a very
nice and comfy foam bed I opted against
memory foam I do not like memory foam it
is terrible we can see there are some
lights here on both sides so if you want
some reading and there's one person that
way in one person this way I can
actually fully extend when I'm sitting
up here laying here we got power outlet
here we have this monitor which is
built-in isn't that fancy and this arm
although I lock it down right now
can fully swing all the way to the other
side we got the chair here and this is
designed so that I can set a camera here
my laptop and I can film videos and do
editing in production I'm on the road
PlayStation is plugged in and here our
controls we have two pumps right here
they're both off one of these pumps
turns the water on so that the shower
will flow the other pump turns the drain
on this right here is an Internet
booster I have on the roof I can
actually show you the roof now appears
my junk drawer just a shelf where I have
much at loose trash and I have some big
speakers they're currently off and then
these sheets are just here for now I'm
gonna use these to wrap the foam again
so for the most part this is where I'll
be sleeping we've got some towels hung
up here some shorts a hat this is the
van and for those that are wondering
there's actually a hard to velcro right
here and I have a switch a we I'm not a
we oh my god a Nintendo switch
I call him a Wii for some reason and I
can pull this off and stick on the
different system but I prefer
PlayStation so now let's close this and
I'll show you some other really basic
stuff this up here AC unit now the best
part is because I've seen a lot of
videos where they're like I have so much
power and electricity or I didn't want
to get an AC unit because it takes too
much juice I have 1,000 amp hours in
here but in order to get to that I'm
gonna need Neil to explain it so before
we do that check this out this right
here not just a bench you can actually
pull this whole thing up slide it out
this comes off
and turns into it combines essentially
and this is kind of a guest cot so
technically as it stands right now you
could get two people on that comfortably
and one person here if you really wanted
to but there's still a couple more
really fun things so let me see if I can
get in here this chair swings forward
then there's a lever right here which I
will pull and then the whole thing
rotates so you could theoretically sleep
uncomfortably right here although I
wouldn't recommend it but at any rate
you could sit down in this chair and
have a really cool chair now in order to
get to the technical aspects I know many
of you may be wondering about the
electronics the components the battery
and the water pump and the water tank
and it's all under here in order to show
this to you I need to bring in Neil and
his crew because admittedly I didn't
build this I work way too much and so I
had to call in the experts so let's jump
to Neil and see you know he'll give us
the rundown how's it going man let's
let's go in the back and you can explain
what's in the van and how it works
so first this is my cooler this is not
to keep things cold it's to stop things
from getting hot and it works I don't
even know what's in there I know isn't
there a hose and cans of cans of beans
I guess alright but look at all this
stuff I have no idea what that stuff is
it's probably hard to see but um we got
a hot water heater we got a power cable
so Neal set it up you I just explained
yeah so basically we have 800 watts of
solar on the roof
there's a thousand amp hours of
batteries on the other side of that wall
what we did was build a partition so the
batteries are on one side the water
tanks back there and then the hot water
heaters here solar on the roof and the
alternator will charge the batteries or
in your park wherever you you know
you're gonna stay for a while you can
plug in there's a 40 amp charger here
which will charge the battery bank plus
the vehicle battery up front when you
plug in the transfer switch will send
power from the side plug to these
breaker boxes here or if you turn the
inverters on there's two or 3000 watt
inverter so they'll send power to the
same breaker boxes this is just DC
fusing for the lights in the back and
then there's a relay that sends power up
because we have freeze protection system
in there so what does a freeze
protection do so the freeze protection
keeps your black water and your gray
work tanks from freezing when it gets
too cold out
oh so exam turn then when it gets cold
you see the water pump back there yeah
so there's 10 as you can see it but that
plastic you can see the water that gray
line that's the water in the tank and
there's a red campbell's for electricity
and yeah there's little lights I don't
know if it matters cuz right right out
this side is just like a utility closet
yeah storage area but what else do what
else we need to look at do we need to
look at anything else you know we'll
flip the bed up and then you can look at
the battery the inverter alright
so it's kind of hard to see so there's
for these 8d AGM batteries and two 3000
watt inverter there's an isolator that
takes the alternator charge and then
charges these batteries and then the
little black box up top will actually
take the solar power on the roof send 90
percent to these batteries ten percent
to the vehicle battery you recently what
do you do you combine you two you
combine them to a single unit yeah so we
put this four hot wire in here and
combine them all together is that gonna
be better for district distributing the
load well you'll get a longer run time
since you primarily use your air
conditioner on the ACS and most now
these two batteries that were dedicated
only to the hot water heater are now
tethered together with this battery bank
originally we set up as these two
batteries to this inverter these to this
inverter now it's both and burgers
pulling off the same Bank you're rarely
going to use this just for your hot
we're here right so now you've got you
have the full power here the whole time
plus we went from 50/50 on the solar to
now 90 percent back here you have the
important lesson is for anybody who
wants to get a van is that the water
tank under my bed typically maintains
the same temperature as the ambient
temperature so I haven't actually been
using the hot water heater because the
water is usually around 80 something
degrees anyway not that it's that hot in
here but uh yeah cool man
so other than that I think the only real
thing there anything else you want to
explain well we're well I mean you just
have control over the solar if you
wanted to have different charge rates
you have you ality to do that you have
your remotes here for her inverters your
water pumps are here I don't need these
inverters anymore do I know you still do
you're still going to turn this on to
keep the power on okay you know it's
drunk in the same the same thing and
then you have your transfer pump for
your shower that's going to pump from
the shower that's on this side to the
holding tank well that's some get your
regular wear pump for your toilet shower
and that is for the wine guard that's on
the top so that's
I guess the rest of stuff I can just
explain or maybe I already did I don't
know we'll see what happens but uh
thanks for the assistance very good you
want to mention give website or anything
diversify people services I'll put in
the link below so if those are watching
there's a link and Neil does a ton of
work exact pull pictures have gun racks
and police vehicles but he also put this
together for me so demon
camper vans and pretty much your
business on wheels so what do you think
of someone's on the east coast they
should hit you up anywhere yeah man it
was really hard to find a company yeah I
mean so you know we're about to get a
couple supply trucks shipped across the
country because there's no a lot of
people doing it so there you go right
man appreciate it thank you very cool
all right how can you guys close the
back for me real quick
so that's basically it um you know
there's water in the tank right now and
this is the plan now admittedly as I go
into the wilds with this beautiful
monstrosity it's very tall in here
probably gonna be doing it alone and I
don't really care I'm not really
concerned about that I know it's kind of
like a big deal for some reason people
are looking into solo traveling but I
think the reason they're looking into
solo travels so much is because they
plan on doing it themselves which is
what I plan on doing so I guess that's
about it if you follow this channel and
subscribe you will likely see a tinge of
political content as I explore this
country and maybe other countries on
this continent or maybe even in South
America too and talk with people about
their lives to explore an experience
it's not gonna be a very silly or vapid
thing it's probably to be a bit serious
but it's gonna be fun
I don't know the production schedule
will be like all I know is this channel
exists I'm gonna be producing thanks for
hanging out and subscribe if you haven't
and I've got other channels too so go to
youtube.com slash Tim cast if you care
for politics you might get really angry
because there's a big divide between
like van life and political commentary
but hey that's what I do so thanks for
hanging out and I will see you all in
the next video